[Music]
for thousands of years the culture of
ancient Egypt has been admired and
coveted today some of the greatest
artifacts of Egyptian culture are found
thousands of miles away from the land
that created them and that angers dr.
Zahi Hawass what they beam to steal this
artifacts devoted to their museums and
they damage the value of the tomb and
they damage a sport and they damaged a
civilization
dr. who was is the man in charge of
Egypt's antiquities and he's got a wish
list of items he'd like to see come home
to look at the bust of Nefertiti and the
zodiac that shows the sky at the Louvre
and the Statue of the architect of the
Great Pyramid him you know every piece
that has this body stolen from Egypt it
should come back at the top of his list
is the greatest prize the rosetta stone
it was really my dream to see in a hole
at the Cairo Museum looking at the
rosetta stone it is the icon of our
Egyptian identity
the Rosetta Stone arguably the most
important Egyptian artifact ever
unearthed this nearly one-ton Rock is
engraved with messages in ancient Greek
and to hieroglyphic scripts by comparing
the Greek to the hieroglyphs scholars
were able to crack the hieroglyphic code
and for the first time understand the
meaning of the ancient Egyptian language
it's an object that's important to all
of humanity it's important for all of us
to have access to to seeing an object
that's that's as significant as the
Rosetta Stone and I think that's why we
feel it's important for it to be to be
based here in the museum Hanna Bolton is
a spokeswoman for the British Museum
where the Rosetta Stone has been on
display for the last two centuries
the Rosetta Stone came into the museum's
collection historically when it was
originally found by Napoleon and when he
took his archaeologists and invaded
Egypt and they discovered the rosetta
stone and when the British beat Napoleon
they took the material that he had
collected
so the British seized from the French
what the French seized from the
Egyptians you're talking about material
that's been in museum collection
particular in terms of the British
Museum often for - over 200 years 250
years and therefore it has a history
within this collection but the history
of the object here has been about 200
years the history of the object from
where it came from is about how many
thousands of thousands of years but
thousands of years under the sand right
so it isn't a quote you're not talking
about a situation where for 2,000 years
you know people were able to go and see
that object in in Egypt but you know all
those material is uncovered and
excavated and it's actually only at that
point that you start to get this this
sort of issue of where it should be
always where it should be on display
because that's when you've discovered it
Gary Vee con director of the Walters Art
Museum in Baltimore believes the
question of ownership is complicated the
English and the French have contributed
to what the Rosetta Stone is the red is
that rosetta stone didn't come out of
the ground with a neon sign on it saying
I'm important by the way it took work it
took knowledge and that I think has to
translate into some sense of at least
metaphysical what if just say if you
know Egyptians had invaded Britain 200
years ago they had found stones massive
stones and carted them back to Egypt and
their Egyptian scholars discovered what
they are or what we now know a stone
edge would Britain not be right in
asking for their return I think we can
we come back to this issue about
ownership and I think the the the then
trustees or the trustees it ended up
being set up to run the the Egyptian
Museum if you like would probably use
the same argument that the trustees at
the British Museum use here which is
that actually you know that there is a
need and there's a great benefit to
having a Museum of world civilizations
because you're able to compare and get
Ross there's always new things you can
learn there's always new connections
that you can make
need one person to come and debate with
me to tell me this sentence that you
keep this monument outside of Egypt it
has a value the value of it is in Egypt
not in this museums doctor who was his
passion may just soon pay off he's asked
the British Museum to allow the stone to
be exhibited in Cairo for three months
when Egypt's new giza museum opens in
we lend many thousands of objects for
many hundreds of museums every year and
subject to fitness to travel and
conditions and conservation and so on
there isn't any reason why aspects of
the collection can't be sent on
short-term loans anywhere in the world
it will happen one day that these
artifacts should be shown here for a
short time like three months and it will
happen and perhaps this stone that once
brought about such understanding
centuries ago still has the power to
unite people of two great cultures
[Music]